[Music]
on this Tuesday night a new suspected
case of the corona virus in Canada what
we know about the latest patient and
what about the Canadians under lockdown
in Wuhan China who want out we're
looking at all options plus balancing
fear with facts I asked an expert in
infectious disease about whether trying
to contain it is working the UK says yes
to some Huawei 5g technology defying the
US what will Canada do backlash to
president Trump's Middle East peace plan
why critics say Israel is pulling all
the strings and taking a perilous plunge
in Antarctica this place is under threat
one man's call to action while braving
bone-chilling waters
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are continuing to monitor the
outbreak of the mysterious new corona
virus tonight the number of confirmed
cases in China keeps soaring nearly a
week into the biggest quarantine in
history and another presumptive case has
been identified here in Canada a man in
British Columbia who is in his 40s and
regularly goes to China to work as
isolated himself and is waiting for test
results there are two confirmed cases of
the corona virus in Ontario a husband
and wife both in their 50s who recently
came back from Wuhan the center of the
outbreak the virus has now spread to
Japan and Germany and in both cases
authorities say the people who are ill
did not travel to China themselves but
were in contact with someone who had the
German Ministry of Health now says four
people were infected after attending a
company training event last week with a
colleague from Shanghai as many as 40
people may have come in contact with the
woman in China there are now about 6,000
confirmed cases and at least 132 people
have died most of them in Wuhan the US
and the UK are sending passenger planes
to Wuhan to repatriate their citizens
there are 250 Canadians registered in
the region Foreign Affairs says 126 have
contacted the consulate asking for help
to get home but at this point Canada is
not sending a plane to get them we're
trying to contact everyone assess their
specific need for assisted repatriation
we're at the same time consulting with
their allies and and looking at the
different options that people are
considering the US and the UK have now
upgraded their travel warnings advising
citizens to avoid non-essential travel
to all of mainland China and several
Airlines are cutting back on flights to
China at this point Canada has not
expanded its Travel Warning and is still
advising people to avoid the Wuhan
region and who Bay province Redman
Shannon has our top story tonight as if
further evidence were needed that these
are extraordinary times young younger
son Hong Kong leader Carrie Lam wearing
a face mask an item she banned last year
during the pro-democracy protests Lam
announcing that visitor permits
and most travel from the mainland will
be limited after Thursday night Casillas
Hongkongers like this man think it's too
little too late
eight cases have already been reported
in Hong Kong in Beijing the head of the
World Health Organization met with
Chinese President Xi Jinping they agreed
for a w-h-o team to join the 6,000
Chinese medical staff who've been sent
to the affected region the organization
says the emergency remains confined to
China but the global risk is high so far
it's going back with travelers to two
foreign countries where as the home
country of somebody or travel as such
it's not wildly spreading outside of
China but again we have to be prepared
for in case it would in Wuhan stay TV
shows the much-hyped
building of a special new hospital some
prefabricated rooms already in place
most people living in the city remain
holed up at home mani shouting
encouragement to each other from
apartment windows we are not really sure
if they are reporting the truth or like
if they're under reporting the actual
numbers I think you're just like not
knowing what's actually going on and how
long it's gonna last it like gets them
more scary apart and cities near the
affected who Bay Province are increasing
checks to anyone arriving those with
high temperatures sent to hospital
immediately
and more than a thousand kilometers away
in Beijing some empty shelves and long
lineups as the first death from the
virus is confirmed in the capital
Redmond Shannon global news London now
to what we know about the cases here in
Canada here's Heather Eurex West
health officials say Canada's third
presumed case of novel coronavirus
did everything right this is a gentleman
who was well aware of what was going on
in China and when he returned he went
home and he voluntarily self isolated
the man had recently traveled to Wuhan
China but did not have an
symptoms until more than 24 hours after
he returned this person was not
symptomatic on his flight there's no
risk to people who aren't who are in
contact with somebody with no symptoms
but there are questions within the
global medical community around whether
or not that statement is true normally
with a corona virus we see more viral
shedding and more transmission when a
person is more symptomatic China has
reported there may be evidence of a
symptomatic transmission all of these
questions must and will be answered in
order to provide a proper risk
assessment the Chinese Embassy in Canada
is advising all Chinese nationals
returning from Wuhan to isolate
themselves for 14 days at home so far
all cases across North America have been
traced back to China
the coming days and weeks are likely to
bring more confirmed cases here and
around the world including the
possibility of some person to person
spread Studies on the new corona virus
show that on average one sick person can
infect between 1.5 and 3.5 other people
that makes it a bit more infectious than
most seasonal flu strains in which sick
people can infect between 1 and 1.5
others but less infectious than SARS
which spreads from one to two to five
others it's why public health officials
are doing all they can to prevent an
outbreak isolating and testing anyone
who traveled to WHO by province and has
now become ill we need to be very
vigilant there are people who have
travelled who are here who might be
incubating this virus who might be
becoming sick in the next couple of
weeks and that's why it's so critical
that we maintain our focus because the
success of their efforts will be
measured in the days ahead
hether your ex West Global News Calgary
as this story keeps evolving there are
many questions and it's important to
balance fear with facts so to help us do
that I'm joined again by dr. Michael
guard him he's an infectious disease
specialist and chief of staff at Humber
River Hospital in Toronto dr. garden
let's start with the news of the
confirmed cases in Germany and Japan in
both cases the people had not traveled
to China the man in Germany was in
contact with a woman who had come from
Wuhan but apparently did not have any
symptoms until she was on the flight
back there does that
raise alarm bells for you about the
virus spreading and possibly spreading
when people don't have symptoms well you
know certainly seeing cases that are
occurring in places where this has been
imported where somebody who travelled
has given it to somebody else we've been
we've been looking for that the whole
time along so that isn't the big
surprise the issue here is how
contagious is this virus when people
have mild symptoms and honestly it's
really hard to sort of set world wide
policy on one case right so we really
need to be cautious saying that the
virus is highly infectious in that
setting
typically with viruses people are mildly
contagious if they have minimal symptoms
and they're much more contagious if they
have a lot of symptoms so it's it's
possible it can certainly transmit if
people have mild disease or maybe even
no symptoms but it's certainly less
likely than if they're sick so is it too
early than to be definitive about the
transmissibility of this virus when
people are contagious and it how exactly
it's spreading absolutely I mean we need
to take a step back I mean typically
with other viruses what we've done is
we've looked at people where we we have
a good idea when they got infected and
then we're doing serial swabbing on them
to see at what point they start to shed
the virus at what point that they start
to develop symptoms none of that has
been done with this particular virus so
I think we are too early to get very
definitive about how it is transmitted
if we take a big step back though and
look at the epidemiology the spread
seems to be similar to what we saw
during SARS which is that people who are
sick are the most likely ones who are
actually spreading it well given the
unknowns and given what you just said
should people who have been to the wuhan
region B style self isolating as a
precaution right now that's not
recommended I mean it's a very good
question right now what we're looking at
is people who have who have symptoms
that may change over time but you can
imagine if we start to broaden that case
definition we're now anybody who comes
from Wuhan is isolated or take it even
further a lot of calls I've been getting
today is why are we isolating every
person who's even been in China you can
imagine that very quickly overwhelms the
Public Health System so early on we have
to be very sort of surgical in what
we're doing and if necessary we start to
move out
we have to remember the area that's been
locked down we're talking 35 and some
million people so the vast majority of
people from that region do not have this
virus okay
well watch and wait and hopefully speak
with you again dr. garden thank you
thanks for having me
two other news tonight the u.s. says it
is disappointed the UK government has
given Huawei the go-ahead to build parts
of its new 5g network president Donald
Trump claims the Chinese tech giant
can't be trusted and is a threat to
national security but it is the world
leader in 5g technology and as Abigail
Beeman reports Canada too is on the cusp
of making a big decision about it
British ministers meeting at 10 Downing
Street to discuss Huawei deciding to
allow the company to be part of a future
5g network with restrictions so-called
high risk vendor involvement is capped
at 35 percent and they're not allowed to
be part of the core we're sensitive
personal data is kept we would never
take decisions that threaten our
national security or the security of our
five eyes partners the decision goes
against what the US wanted they're
worried about Chinese influence and it
leaves Canada as the only member of the
five eyes intelligence network yet to
make a huawei decision Australia and New
Zealand banned it we know how important
it is to make sure that there is both
competitiveness in the Canadian industry
but also security for Canadian users
that's why we're working with our five
eyes allies working with international
partners looking at the security
concerns doesn't seem to me that it's in
our interests to to accept that risk
you don't think Canada's own former head
of CSIS Wardell Cox says Canada is in a
different situation from the Brits they
probably can push the envelope more than
we can we have a communication system
which was integrated which is integrated
with the American system I think that
makes our problem harder than it is for
the British we're very respectful of
that process we're participating in that
process and all we've ever asked and I
think it's fair for Canadians to expect
this is that any decision on Huawei in
Canada is made based on cybersecurity
and technology and not based on politics
of course there is a broader context to
Canadians detained in China and Huawei
executor
moong Wong Jo in the middle of an
extradition case under house arrest in
Vancouver I think it's very important
that we get to Mike respect but it's not
directly tied to that decision is it
holding back you see the Public Safety
Minister wouldn't answer he says they're
working on a made in Canada solution
while experts save the decision is
likely to be a no they don't expect it
to come anytime soon
given the high stakes with China Abigail
Beeman Global News Ottawa if the federal
government decides not to go with Huawei
then what Rogers is the only big telecom
company to begin rolling out a
fifth-generation Network in Canada it's
partnered with Swedish supplier Ericsson
to provide the technology BCE Bell
Canada enterprises and Telus have yet to
select a vendor they're awaiting a
decision from Ottawa nokia could be a
big contender the federal government
announced 40 million dollars in funding
to the Finnish telecom giant last year
to conduct research on 5g wireless
technology in Canada and Samsung is also
a major player it's already secured a
deal to supply equipment to Quebec's
Videotron the case against Cameron ortus
was back in court today in Ottawa he's
the high ranking civilian intelligence
official with the RCMP accused of
violating Canada's secrecy laws charges
laid against artists were moved to the
Superior Court by the Crown prosecutor
to speed up the trial his lawyers says
he's having issues communicating with
his client because of concerns they
might breach the security of Information
Act or dismiss arrested in September
last year charged with preparing to
share sensitive information with a
foreign entity or terrorist organization
and with sharing operational information
in 2015 his bail was revoked in November
and he's being in custody ever since we
now know the full cost of the failed
prosecution of retired Vice Admiral Marc
Norman the federal government spent more
than 1.4 million dollars on the breach
of trust case new documents tabled in
the House of Commons don't reveal the
breakdown of those costs in 2015 norman
was accused of leaking cabinet secrets
about a federal shipbuilding contract
worth nearly 700 million dollars Norman
was suspended and last May the crown
stayed the charge after a determined
there was no reasonable prospect of
conviction Norman retired from the
millet
cheri after reaching an undisclosed
financial settlement with the federal
government Palestinians are furious
tonight at the American president
coming up why Trump's plan for peace has
ignited protests
President Trump has unveiled his plan
for Middle East peace he calls it the
deal of the century but one party to it
the Palestinians were nowhere in sight
today Israel's Prime Minister was though
Benjamin Netanyahu who was indicted at
home today on charges of bribery fraud
and breach of trust was by Donald
Trump's side critics say that's the
problem that this plan cannot possibly
lead to peace because it's an Israeli
plan wrapped in an American envelope
Jackson prosecco explains believing he
can defy history President Donald Trump
revealed his plan to bring peace to the
Middle East all prior administration's
from President Lyndon Johnson have tried
and bitterly failed but I was not
elected to do small things or shy away
from big problems the 80 page proposal
strongly favors Israel it was drafted by
Trump's son-in-law Jared Kushner and is
already backed by Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu it addresses the root
cause of the conflict the incident by
insisting that the Palestinians will
finally have to recognize Israel as the
Jewish state the plan would redraw the
map creating a Palestinian state with
limited sovereignty Israeli settlements
in the West Bank would remain Israel
would also keep control over Jerusalem's
holy sites under this vision Jerusalem
will remain Israel's undivided very
important undivided capital almost
immediately protests erupted in Jordan
while Palestinian leaders who were not
at the table branded the plan as a
conspiracy it just looks like Trump with
all of his strong support of Israel from
the get-go is yet one more time try to
do a favor for his friends in Jerusalem
and Tel Aviv that's what it feels like
to most people previous American
presidents have tried to bring the two
sides together to negotiate that too
ended in failure
Trump's plan was likely dead the moment
it was announced but it's already being
used as a road map by Netanyahu who
plans to move ahead to annex West Bank
settlements in the coming days
Jackson proce co Global News Washington
I had the surprised protest against a
controversial tennis player
in California investigators from the
National Transportation Safety Board say
the helicopter that NBA legend Kobe
Bryant was on descended suddenly at
2,000 feet a minute and described the
crash as a high-energy impact
investigators spent all day documenting
the crash scene the remains of the
chopper and all the bodies have now been
removed the crash killed Bryant his 13
year old daughter and all seven others
on board it was foggy at the time and
the pilot had received special
permission to fly in low visibility
conditions the helicopter did not have a
terrain awareness warning system on
board
despite the NTSB recommending the FAA
make it mandatory on all helicopters
like the one Bryant was on it helps
prevent unintentional impacts with the
ground to tennis greats are using the
Australian Open as a platform to protest
the legacy of a well-known Australian
player there's only one thing longer
than the list of Margaret courts tennis
achievements it's her list of offensive
and homophobic statements that's John
McEnroe he's criticizing the Australian
Open for honoring Margaret Court on the
50th anniversary of her grand slam she
holds the record for Grand Slam singles
titles and she's been widely criticized
for her homophobic and racist views
today Martina Navratilova grabbed the
mic at Melbourne's Margaret Court arena
to demand the name of that arena be
changed the live feed was cut off as she
tried to address the crowd the two
tennis stars then unfurled a banner to
rename the arena after indigenous
champion Evonne Goolagong Cawley next
why a swimmer took a Polar Plunge
through Antarctica's ice glaciers it's
been two centuries since Antarctica was
discovered and the anniversary is being
marked by a sobering world record an
Englishman known as the human polar bear
has completed the first ever swim under
the Antarctic Ice Sheet it's part of his
campaign to raise awareness about the
impact of climate change and the
region's dire need for political
protection
Geoff Semple explains
the world's coldest continent is both
perilous and peaceful Antarctica's icy
landmass twice the size of Australia
remained hidden untouched by humans
until 200 years ago now we've been down
there all the world was on the charts
was ice that was that was it so he went
actually off the charts this Russian
naval officer was the first person known
to have laid eyes on Antarctica's ice
shelf in 1820 that discovery sparked a
rush of hunters and other explorers
seeking to plant their flag and lay
their claim to Earth's final frontier
countries for example went to great
lengths to put their Antarctic stations
all over Antarctica and to raise
national flags to say we're here we're
busy this is ours some countries such as
Argentina even transported a pregnant
woman to give birth on the frozen
continent hoping to strengthen their
claim today those territorial tensions
are mostly kept at bay thanks to a
global treaty of more than 50 countries
including Canada to promote scientific
cooperation but the continent now faces
a much greater existential threat
Antarctica has been frozen for millions
of years at the end of the last ice age
the continents Ice Sheet was shrinking
at a rate of around one meter per year
but scientists warn that process is
accelerating the ice melting six times
faster as climate change turns up the
heat Lewis Pugh has seen the impact of
rising sea levels up close the British
endurance swimmer nicknamed the human
polar bear just became the first person
to swim beneath an Antarctica ice sheet
to show the world what it's about to
lose
anything as beautiful Issus scientists
recently revealed that underwater
glacial melting is happening up to a
hundred times faster than they thought
this place needs protecting it needs
protecting because all our futures
depend on it
view is now calling on those same
countries who agreed to share this
continent to also help ensure it doesn't
look much different 200 years from now
Geoff sample global news and that's
global national for this Tuesday I'm
donor freezin tighter Canada is an
update on those two as M bony drivers
who use their homemade Zamboni to clear
their backyard rink in vernon bc there
they are the vancouver canucks invited
them to help clear the big rink and even
mascot fin lent a hand or a fin thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]